all right joining me now is mike pompeo
former secretary of state and fox news
contributor mr secretary
how could the intelligence on the
taliban's strength be off by so much
laura this was a terrible execution of
an incredibly important mission
president trump uh campaigned on and
then for four years demanded that we
find the path forward in afghanistan
where we got our young men and women
home it was the right path that we were
headed down
we tried to work to try and find peace
and reconciliation but make no mistake
about it the taliban knew
they knew that if they didn't do the
things that we asked them to do if they
didn't honor their agreements that they
threatened an american if they even so
much as scared an american that we would
bring
real cost and we did that we did it time
and time again we had drawn down from a
bit over 15 000 to just over 2500 by the
time we departed and we had managed to
keep a stable place we had managed to
make sure we protected americans we had
the embassy secured with all of the
things that you've seen fall apart over
the last 96 hours in a way that
just reflects so poorly on the all the
blood and treasure and
work that we have done for those 20
years it didn't have to be this way it
is not about whether we got our folks
out president biden spent a lot of time
talking about that today it was about
the how we execute that and the failures
that we'd had for all of these years
we had come to an understanding with our
adversaries the taliban we weren't about
to recognize them we weren't about to
beg them to protect our embassy we made
clear these are the expectations these
are conditions that you have to meet
they hadn't met them and so we were
continuing to our work to get our boys
and girls home but we weren't about to
allow what we've seen happen these last
96 hours happened on our watch
what are the chances mr secretary that
president biden and blinken have already
struck a deal with the taliban to be
able to remove
thousands of people from that airport
over the next week or so what are the
chances of that deal having been struck
already and we'll never know what was
what if it had been what what price had
been paid
yeah
i i i hope the probability is low i pray
that it is uh
maybe they've got that done might but
that would that would actually uh
suggest that they actually had a plan
you talked about all the planning and
contingencies you don't put four or five
six thousand people back in for
something you've planned for after you
just took them out this is clearly
unplanned activity i'd be surprised if
they have that kind of agreement and if
they do i want to know what it is this
is going to cost the united states of
america in terms of our
morality in terms of the risk from the
rest of the world
laura i've said this time and time again
we we had a deterrence model we knew
that strength created peace and we know
that weakness begets war you are seeing
the summers the you're seeing the some
result of the weakness of the
administration whether it's our southern
border whether it's handing the russians
a pipeline completion
that can threaten europe all of these
things the whole world watches chairman
kim xi xingping they are all watching
what's happening today and i hope this
administration comes to understand that
apologizing placating appeasing being
weak only presents risks to american
security
yesterday in an interview liz cheney had
something to say about you sir watch
president biden bears responsibility for
making this decision
but there is no question that president
trump his administration secretary
pompeo they also bear very significant
responsibility for this they walk down
this path of legitimizing the taliban
the notion of we're going to end endless
wars that campaign slogan what we're
watching right now in afghanistan is
what happens when america withdraws from
the world
uh mr secretary your response
yeah i look i think she's lost the
bubble just a bit
in the end
we demonstrated that we could in fact
conduct the american security mission in
afghanistan we had a plan both to get
our folks home
and a plan to make sure that we reduced
the risk that we'd ever be attacked from
that place again we had a plan to do it
we were well on our way to executing
that
january 20th by administration took over
and they pulled the last pin out of the
jungle pile without having thought about
the ramifications that would result so
i think i think congresswoman janey just
thinks that we should have been there
forever another 30 billion dollars a
year i i went to some of those transfers
of the dignified the dignified transfers
of remains at dover
our young men and women did amazing work
there the young soldiers our young
airmen did remarkable work it was time
to get our team home we could have done
it in a way that would have reflected
well on america and would have protected
the interest we had i think
representative cheney just simply has a
different view she thinks we ought to be
there putting our kids at risk to do
things that america simply has no vital
interest in
secretary pompeo this is a catastrophic
failure you've said it so many people
today with enormous experience have said
the same thing
where should the accountability lie for
this we have a president of the united
states who's currently at camp david
he's gone back there
um we have people who went before
congress time and again and said things
were pretty much on track we had some
challenges but things were going well
this went on for 10 12 years we were
getting those updates uh should
secretary austin remain in his position
should mark milly remain in his
boy there's a lot of work that needs to
be done to hold the leadership
accountable maybe not even just
this set some there may well be history
that began 10 11 12 years ago that we
need to go back and look at but laura as
i think about these things our
constitution demands that the senior
leader our commander-in-chief be held
accountable you know we got handled lots
of challenges when we walked into office
north korea was
building up its program
the previous administration given back a
fifth of ukraine we had lots of
challenges we didn't pass the buck we
didn't blame them we just dealt with
them we confronted them we took them on
president biden is the one that needs to
be held accountable for what's taking
place in afghanistan today and anything
that befalls the united states as a
result of the decisions he made on the
way he executed this withdrawal in such
a hasty unplanned
way that that upended so much of the
good work that had already been done
he needs to be held accountable and he
needs to make accountable those members
of his team but in the end but the end
this falls to presidents laura
yeah and finally sir uh china has uh
made no uh qualms this has no qualms
about expressing its desire
to take advantage of the situation
middle mineral rights the belton road
initiative trade through the region
and obviously looking at taiwan
with hungry eyes
what's happening there tonight and what
is your final comment on china
solar with respect to the things that'll
happen in afghanistan and western china
good luck to the chinese communist party
they're going to face some of the same
challenge that everybody who's taken on
this task of trying to build afghanistan
it is a mess they were a completely
corrupt set of leaders there so i think
they'll face real challenges i'm much
more worried about what they'll do in
the east with respect to taiwan they
have seen that america is not prepared
to defend the basic promises that it
made under this leadership team i hope
this administration will do something
something to demonstrate not just words
but something to demonstrate that we are
prepared to do the right thing by the
people of taiwan it will be really
important to establish that deterrence
model especially after these enormous
failures in afghanistan hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else